[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up on tuesday
is the 22nd anniversary
of the columbine high school shooting it
is unthinkable that it has been that
long i remember it
vividly i was pretty little at the time
but i i remember that it
totally changed the culture changed the
the way news was covered i mean really
changed the way
we thought about our schools and
obviously a lot of it
still on the news a lot of school
shootings a lot of
proposals from politicians to you know
stop the school shootings by getting rid
of all the guns
i guess right now we don't even really
have a lot of schools open a lot of
pushes by the teacher unions to keep
schools
completely closed we are joined now by
someone who saw
those horrible events firsthand craig
scott
who was present it was a student at
columbine during the shooting
whose sister was the first victim of the
shooters and who has been speaking out
on
not just the shooting but on on
solutions to these kinds of problems
for more than 20 years since then craig
thank you so much for coming on the show
absolutely love your show thanks for
having me on that's very kind thank you
so for those who don't remember you know
there's a
lot of youths who watch this show who
and who listen who maybe
who maybe actually don't remember that
shooting i hate to hate to bring you
back to a
terrible time but i know you've you've
recounted this a number of times over
the years
can you just uh bring us back to
what that moment means for you
today 22 years later
yeah well it's a day in history in
american history and if
viewers are watching that weren't uh
born when the shooting happened it was a
day that kind of
time stood still in our country and
anyone that was of age
remembers exactly where they were what
they were doing when it when it happened
much like september 11th
so it was the center of a lot of media
attention because we were wondering why
is this
why could this how could this happen and
how was it in our culture that we got to
a place where
something like this would happen and so
that day
i uh went to school with my sister
uh we were got into a little argument
in the car on our way to school because
i was making us late i was
i spent too much time on my hair and uh
we got into an argument in a fight and i
started to call her names and we pulled
up to the school
and i got out of the car and i slammed
the car door shut
not knowing that'd be the last time i'd
see her i went to my classes and then to
the library during my lunch period
to study for a test i heard some popping
noises coming from outside the school
it was near the end of the school year
so i thought maybe some seniors were
pulling a prank and had brought some
firecrackers to school
and uh just hearing these poppy noises
for a couple minutes and then this
teacher ran into the room she was
completely frantic
she ran over the phone and called the
police and started yelling at all of us
students to hide and get underneath
tables
and so i got underneath the table of two
of my friends matt and isaiah
and underneath the table hearing the
poppy noises uh becoming louder and
louder and then the shooters coming into
the school
and uh i started to realize this wasn't
a prank this was serious
and my two friends just started to freak
out very scared
and frantic and i felt like i heard
a voice within just telling me to be
still and so i
i became very quiet and very still while
my friends were kind of freaking out
and the poppy noise is getting louder
and louder and the shooters were
throwing bombs as they were
pipe bombs as they were coming towards
the library and
the library was the first room that they
came into immediately shooting off their
guns
they were taunting or making fun of
students before they shot or killed them
they'd peek underneath the table and say
peekaboo and shoot a girl
they came over to where i was and they
saw my friend isaiah
isaiah was one of the very few black
students at our school
and the shooters dwelled on a lot of
negative media
on a daily basis and and also one of
their role models was hitler
and so when one of the shooters saw
isaiah he said hey we have an n word
over here
a racial slur and then the other shooter
came over and they drug them out from
underneath the table
calling them racial slurs and then they
shot
he tried to back up and uh the last
thing that he said was i want to see him
see my mom and they shot and killed
isaiah they shot and killed matt right
next to me
and now the whole time i just laid down
being very still
and trying not to draw any attention to
myself and they left me underneath that
table
and um shortly after they left the
library
with 10 students dead or dying and over
over a dozen wounded
and i thought i was gonna die my ears
are ringing so loud from the shotgun
blast
i thought they were bleeding and i
wasn't sure if they were still in the
room
but my heart was pounding so so much i
literally felt like i was gonna have a
heart attack
and so i prayed and asked that my fear
be taken away it was just too much for
me to handle
and in that moment i felt relief for my
fear and felt like i heard
god speak to me and tell me to get out
of there
and so i was the first student to stand
up i listened to that voice and i was
the first one to stand up
looked around and i saw the shooters
were gone i yelled at everyone come on
let's get out of here and at first no
one moved everyone was too scared
and again kind of rallied let's get out
of here and i heard someone asking for
help
and i turned around behind me was a girl
rocking back and forth underneath the
computer
desk she had had her shoulder blown off
from a shotgun blast
and she was asking for help over and
over and i helped to pick her up and a
group of us ran out of an emergency exit
and there was a police car outside and
we all
ran for our lives to get behind that
police car
and i can't really describe the amount
of
joy the amount of just
exhilaration that when i got behind that
car just to be alive
i was just so happy to be alive but at
the same time i felt bad for leaving my
friends
underneath that table and other police
cars began to come by and pick up
students
right before i left uh someone tapped me
on the shoulder and said i think there's
a girl's
a girl that's been shot over there and
he points over to to towards the
library exit door that we ran out of
and it was my sister
my sister had been the first one killed
right outside the school library
and so um for the next couple years i
had a real
hard journey and dealt with a lot of
different things a lot of different
emotions and was just pretty broken
and dysfunctional and my mind was kind
of fragmented
and with a lot of grief a lot of anger
and um and so that was the the worst day
of my life
but it also has led to the most purpose
in my life
and now 22 years later
looking back i'm thankful for everything
that i went through because it's made me
who i am it's also helped me
to really help a lot of people a lot of
teenagers across the country
so i do a lot of speaking in schools and
share lessons learned behind the
columbine shooting
and i also share my sister's story she
had a pretty incredible story we made it
into a movie it was in theaters a couple
years ago and
actually one of your producers ben
davies is in the movie
and he plays uh one of my sister's best
friends he's an actor
i was going to try to work in some kind
of insult about him there but he does a
great job he does a great job in the
movie so i can't yeah
well maybe we could we still have time
for in the interview he's a great guy
and he's the reason i'm on the show and
um
so we've we've been telling her story
now for last over 20 years and millions
and millions of students
now look to her as a role model um she
wrote
something really cool a month before she
was killed in class
in an essay she wrote she titled it my
ethics my codes of life
and in the essay she talked about her
values and her beliefs
and she talked about being a leader she
talked about
showing forgiveness mercy to people not
being quick to judge
anybody not being quick to to judge just
by an impression
or by someone's appearance but to look
deeper look into their soul look into
their heart
and um so in this essay she said i have
this theory
that if one person will go out of their
way to show compassion
then it will start a chain reaction of
the same and people will never know how
far just a little bit of kindness can go
and she handed her ended her essay by
saying you just may start a chain
reaction
and at the same time she wrote this
paper a month before the shooting the
two shooters made a
videotape in their parents basement
without their parents knowing
and um it's called they're called the
basement tapes they were never released
in public but victims families got to
see them
at the very end of the video one of them
picked up a sawed-off shotgun that he
used to kill
isaiah and pointed it at the camera and
said we need a kickstarter revolution we
need to get a
effing chain reaction going here
and he was talking about starting a
chain reaction of school shootings that
was actually something that they wanted
to to kick start and um they have
they've they've there's been some
copycat shootings have been
some people that have idolized them and
and studied what they did and looked up
to them
but my sister's chain reaction is far
outreach there so
um i you know i talk to
kids a lot about um if you allow it the
worst things that happen to you in your
life can become
a source of your biggest strength and
can become a part of your purpose
and lead you to being a deeper person
and um and so uh
yeah i it's been 22 years and i'm still
going i'm still sharing her story still
sharing my story
so i want to get in a moment to
to this ideological aspect that you've
alluded to these these shooters
were uh admirers of hitler they wanted
to start a sort of chain reaction a kind
of
political revolution very often in the
media these guys
and and similar criminals are are
depicted as having been bullied or you
know it was really they were just
reacting to mean old society
i think the reality of this is far
different they were looking at other
targets that sort of thing so i want to
get to that in one second
but i i would like to go back for a
moment to something you said which is
you're you're there you're underneath
the table somehow you survive your
friends are dying around you somehow you
survive you
you hear this voice you you sense a kind
of
divine voice or providence you get out
of there
and then you have this relief and this
joy that you're behind the cop car and
you survived you have this horrible
realization that your sister
is there has been killed for his first
death and
you go through this very difficult
period
sounds like you're quite christian you
know i know that that to be true
so can you just take us through that how
you can
believe in god experience basically the
most horrific thing you can possibly
experience
go through a very difficult period of
your life and then still
believe that there is some providence
that that god would permit this to
happen how you how you could make sense
of that problem well i was taught
by my father who's a really great
teacher
um he taught me a verse out of scripture
that basically in essence talks about
being a see-through
and there's a verse that says if your
eye is single it is full of light
and if it is dual it is full of darkness
and so i have this principle in my life
that i was taught earlier on
to be able to see through both the good
and the bad
that happens in my life and that there
there is a purpose and everything that
happens in my life and if i can discover
what that is if i can be in touch with
it
then things that happen happen for a
reason and i don't have to
escape my problems i don't have to um
uh see things in a dual way but i can
know that there's
i do believe in god and i believe in a
in a source that's ultimately in control
and having that faith really michael
that's the biggest
i have a number of keys of of healing
for me over the years
but really having that um
was was the biggest thing for my healing
and how i tap into that is i just
practice stillness and that was uh
that's something that i do
um and i even talked to kids about it
and you don't have to be a religious
person
um and and i don't go and push religion
when i
speak but i do talk about faith i do
talk about believing in something bigger
than yourself
and believing in your own value and your
own purpose
um that you have great potential within
you just by being a person
and but um the stillness is was huge for
me just spending time
because on the outside you know michael
it looked like nothing but a bloody
tragedy
nothing good but if i could practice
stillness then then
then god or spirit or whatever you were
conscious
could speak to me and tell me how
i could get through this tell me what i
needed to do
tell me how this was ultimately going to
lead to
me becoming a better person and being
able to help
more people and so that was the biggest
key factor was just
um having that faith in my life you know
it's it's a beautiful beautiful
explanation that that you're giving and
it's a
traditional christian explanation of why
why do bad things happen to good people
and it's because in the garden of eden
man sinned and falls out of paradise and
sin and death pervade the world and this
causes all sorts of terrible things
but that there is as you say a purpose
to it a t loss
and so we sing on easter we just sang it
recently on easter
oh happy fault that won for us so great
so glorious a redeemer
that somehow amid all the horrific
things hard to get
much worse than what you went through
there is
a broader providence where whereby god
even can turn
evil things to good and so if you
see that sort of purpose it makes sense
and it makes total sense to me
intellectually until something really
bad happens you know and then
in that moment you just started to think
wait a second hold on wait a minute here
c.s lewis went through this he wrote
that book
problem of pain on this problem of the
odyssey and then his wife is dying and
he said it's a
totally different experience when you've
actually got to live it than
when you know you're just thinking about
it more rationally
now that we are so far removed from it
22 years after the incident what is
i suppose it isn't amazing to me but it
still seems distasteful
is people continue to politicize the
tragedy and what i mean by politicizes
they
they continue to try to read that event
as
a justification for some in some cases
very distantly related
partisan desires and it might be on guns
it might be on
school reform it might be on this that
or the other thing
um do you have any thoughts on any of
those move moments
movements rather and do you have any
suggestions as someone who experienced
it
firsthand going forward
yeah there's definitely uh things that
are taken tragedies
uh events that the media picks up on
that they want to politicize
it uh they want to use it for whatever
cause that they think
um is important or needs or or needs to
happen
and uh you know i've been involved and
interviewed and questioned over
news media i've been over on a thousand
interviews throughout my life
and that that's an issue that comes up a
lot but i
i know that that is a surface level
issue i know that um that when somebody
has
um real darkness real hatred in their
heart
uh that if they want to take the time to
plan and kill people they can find a way
to do it
there was actually a propane tank that
was set at columbine
that was right underneath me i was on
the second floor in the library
directly below me in the cafeteria was a
propane tank if it had gone off it would
have killed
500 kids and we would have been you know
banning propane tanks but the
those i'm not against um
things that make legislation rules that
make things
safer but rules don't change people laws
don't change people's hearts and so the
real
issue is dealing with on a cultural you
can call
i like to think of it as a spiritual but
sometimes it gets labeled as a mental
health thing
but dealing with people's hearts my
program has helped to stop documented
school shootings
and thousands of suicides i have a
book of emails from kids over the years
just that had contemplated suicide
over a thousand of them and that heard
this story and had a change of heart
and so you know i think that um
you know people that that use these
events for their own
uh agenda i think that a lot of them
really believe that that this is the
problem you know they think that the gun
the guns are the problem
but it really wasn't the main problem uh
if you really want to look at i i
know of every school shooting that's
happened since columbine i get
questioned by the media after everyone i
research it i learn about it
and if i were to tell you the biggest
thing the biggest commonality between
all these school shooters
it's pretty simple it's that they focus
on everything that was negative in this
world
they focused on everything that was
negative in themselves and they didn't
see the good
in themselves or in other people and
they had this
perspective of seeing the world they
could have been in the most beautiful
place they could have been in the
sistine chapel in
in italy with michelangelo's beautiful
paintings and found
dirt in the corner and focused on that
and
when you have a view where everything is
dark and jaded
and you see nothing good then in you it
creates
a darkness it creates an anger and a
hatred and what i've learned also about
all these shooters school shootings is
that they all dwelled on a lot of very
negative media
almost on a daily basis and if you can
just imagine
um and you know of course there's
there's there's there's nothing negative
in the media right
when i ask that question to students in
schools i say
you know how many of you guys would
agree there's a lot of negative like
in the media like every hand goes up
yeah negative media it's sort of a
redundant phrase you don't have to say
both right
you know uh it doesn't mean you can't
address the negative or talk about it
but where is your focus
because whatever we place attention on
we give power to
whatever it is whatever the media
chooses to focus on
um the media told this narrative after
columbine that really wasn't true
and columbine was such a covered
thing after the shooting it was on the
news for months
and we had a news camp of reporters near
the school for months
and the narrative that basically came
out was this
two guys are pushed to the edge because
of bullying
and they get revenge at their school the
problem is that's really not the true
story that's really not the main
issue and even the psychologists that
have looked into it
that have looked at everything that
happened don't believe bullying was a
factor they were bullied to a degree at
school i know of a couple stories
i also know kids at my school that were
bullied a lot worse and i also know that
they themselves were bullies
at times and became the ultimate bullies
that day
if i were to tell when i talk to kids i
say the biggest reason they did what
they did
is that they focused on everything that
was negative in this world
and that's that's the bigger reason it's
not bullying
um the bigger reason is is what they
focused on
and so i have a program called value up
and i
named it that after reading um the
book from sue klebold her son was dylan
one of the shooters at columbine
dylan wasn't going to go through with
the shooting he thought eric his friend
who was very
psychopathic um was crazy and he only
decided to go
along with it in the last couple months
of his planning he planned it for a year
and but he was more suicidal and what
his mom said was we
valued dylan but he didn't value himself
and it struck me because i realized i
had already spoken to over a million
teens across
the country in person and i realized
that's such a core issue
when somebody doesn't believe in their
own value
they're not going to treat other people
with value but if they can realize the
truth and whether you want to come out
this from a christian perspective or
other religion that you know christians
you're fearfully wonderfully made
um other perspective that we just have
the capacity within us to do great good
we have so much potential especially
young people
and so if they can realize it doesn't
matter what they look like
it doesn't matter what other people say
about them it doesn't matter where they
come from
who their family is that they have a
great potential
in them to and and the capacity to do
great things
and be a positive influence in this
world like my sister was
she did small things stepped out of her
way for
a a girl that sat all alone during lunch
who just lost her mom in a car accident
a friend a friend told me how he has a
slight disability he was made fun of and
ignored usually ignored a lot at school
his name was adam
and the first time she met him she stood
up a couple guys were
were making fun of him she stood up for
him and he told me
that the time that she reached out to
him he was having thoughts of taking his
life
and after she met him every day in the
hallway she would just say hi to him
and he said he literally started waking
up in the morning
looking forward to this day that this
pretty girl would say hi to him in the
hallway
and a small act of kindness human
connection
what is going to really change our
culture what's real
how are we going to get to the root of
the problem well the root of the problem
is in our hearts the root of the problem
is it really is it those are where the
problems are it's also where the
solutions are
so um you know i again
you know if there's a legislation that
comes up that seems smart
uh that makes it harder for uh criminals
or people that are insane or
um you know to get firearms great i'm
all for it
but if they want to tell me that this is
the answer yeah to the problems
right it's then i say no you're really
looking at it at a from a shallow
point of view and um those those
people that commit these atrocities
break all those rules anyway
uh you could create a hundred more laws
they're gonna
they get them illegally anyway um
so you know it is that argument that it
really it really affects the law abiding
people
than it you know than it does the
criminal well i love your
i love your point here on uh if if you
hate yourself
i'm not saying you you have to be
prideful and you have to think you know
you're the bee's knees and everything
but if you really truly hate yourself
and you just focus in on
all the worst aspects of yourself and of
the world you're going to lash out
you're going to have a
dim view of the world when christ says
love your neighbor as yourself
well if you if you hate yourself and you
treat yourself poorly
then you're you're obviously going to do
the same thing to your neighbor by that
by that principle so i think
that's so smart and your point on
politics you know that at the
legislative level
that's a little bit of the surface level
because uh
you know we we say that politics is
downstream of culture we've all heard
that phrase a lot
and culture is downstream of religion
cult and culture come from the same root
word
what a culture worships is going to
define that culture and so these things
are not so easily separated you do have
to take it down and
when you're thinking of political public
matters you know how we all get along
together
well that is going to begin not just by
focusing on everybody else's problems
it's going to begin with
to quote michael jackson the man in the
mirror that's good you're going to have
to focus on yourself too
if you have a country of vicious people
vicious self-involved miserable sort of
people
then it doesn't matter how many laws
you're going to pass you're going to
have a vicious miserable
nation and so a little uh little
personal self-help can can work too you
know
michael my dad gave he gave a he read a
poem
to the house judiciary of congress uh
three months after the columbine
shooting
and um it was widely uh sent along
forwarded email
internet explorer told us it was the the
most forwarded email in 1999
but he went there um actually
uh the nra had called and my dad's not a
member of the nra he doesn't even own a
gun
and and they said would you come and
share and he
he taught he opened up and saying i'm
you know i'm not here to defend them i'm
not here to support them
i just don't think that that that this
is where the real issue
lies and he read this poem this
beautiful poem
that he actually wrote before knowing he
was going to speak there
and he said your laws ignore our deepest
needs
your words are empty air you've stripped
away our heritage
you've outlawed simple prayer gunshots
fill our classrooms and precious
children die
you seek for answers everywhere and ask
the question why
you regulate restrictive law through
legislative creed
and yet you fail to understand that god
is what we need
and he gave this beautiful speech
talking about how as a country
we used to recognize that we're a
three-part being where body
soul which is our mind our will
intellect and our emotions
and our in a spirit which is an
intuitive thing it's our conscious and
it's also a communion with the divine
and we used to recognize that as a
three-part being for nearly 200 years
the united states was number one
in the world in education as a first
world nation we were number one
and when we were number one my my father
is a scholar in american history
specialized in american education
and he showed me that uh
that every educator knew a motto
it's in teacher training manuals and it
was the three h's
it was before the three r's reading
writing arithmetic and the three h's
were heart
head and hands they believed it was
their job as a teacher
to first teach the hearts of young
people
today the focus of our educational
system the philosophy is knowledge
or academic achievement and even though
that's a great goal
that was secondary when we were number
one today the united states is nowhere
being
near number one as a first world nation
in education
and yet you know that's the goal is to
be the top
when our focus was first teaching
principles of the heart of character and
of course
a lot of this happened a removal of it
in 1963 when we removed
prayer and 10 commandments from school
but what also happened and i'm not
suggesting putting religion back in
school
i am but i but you're a little more
nicer to the other guys but i am saying
that we have to look at
education that touches the hearts of
young people and teaches them real life
principles
because you know what the two shooters
at columbine were very smart
the problem wasn't the education of
their mind it wasn't their knowledge
it's the education their heart and life
principles
and what would have stopped them or
any other of these shooters from doing
what they were planning to do
it would have taken another person
stepping out in compassion
with some love and some truth and
reaching their heart seeing past
their seeing past their exterior seeing
pat's their negative attitude
their words their demeanor and seeing
that this was a person that was hurting
that needed some help that would have
had an impact i'll share one quick story
one week before the shooting happened
eric was really the leader of the two
shooters he actually went to a youth
group meeting and i've met with the
youth pastor
he said that he was given his message
and and all of a sudden
it hit him he said he was not planning
this it hit him out of the blue
he's in the middle of his little message
and
and his spirit speaks to him and says
say this and he stops his message and he
says
i just feel to say this he says there's
somebody here
that is going to do something terrible
soon they're going to hurt themselves
and other people
and i want you to know that this is that
you do not have to go through it
that this is your chance to to change to
repent
turn away from that if you want and eric
harris was sitting there
in that audience and of course he didn't
he didn't he
he he was given a chance to change right
then and there and he didn't
and so um you know if we if we practice
stillness
if we practice and you know all great
philosophers from every
every religion talk about the power of
meditation and prayer
and being still quieting your mind and
listening deep within
and if we get in touch with that then
there's a there's a intuitive voice that
will speak to us
the same voice that talked to me that
day that said be still
that said get out of there it's the same
voice that spoke to my sister
when she was writing in her journals and
in her journal she had this feeling that
she was going to live to be very old
but that god was going to use her to
impact millions she told a number of my
friends
her friends about it and some of my
family she actually said
that she didn't think she was going to
live old enough to get married and the
last
one of the last things that she did was
drew in her journal in class
a half hour before she was killed she
drew this picture
of her eyes crying and 13 tears were
falling from her eyes
watering a rose with drops of blood
coming off from it
she took her this drawing up to her
teacher before class ended and showed
her mrs cruthers
it was later my teacher mrs carruthers
told me that rachel said
she showed her and she said wow rachel
it's beautiful what is it she said
oh it's my tears she said i'm crying and
then she looked at
her teacher and said mrs cruthers i'm
going to have an impact on the world
and her teacher said rachel i have no
doubt of that
she walked out of class and not even a
half an hour later she was killed
and that day there were 13 people that
were killed matching the number of tears
that she drew
and the rose that she drew that had
drops of blood will rose as the u.s
national flower every state has a
state flower and the rose is the
american flower it's the national flower
and she drew the same rose other times
in her journal growing out of a
columbine flower
and when we when my dad first got this
journal and he
got it from the sheriff's department it
had bullets that had had a bullet that
got lodged into it after passing through
her body
he went to go pick up her backpack and
he flipped open to the last page and he
sees this picture
that his daughter drew of her eyes
crying 13 tears
and we found in her journals four other
times she drew the same rose growing up
out of a columbine flower
columbine is the colorado state flower
he felt
that that's that voice speak to him and
said the rose
represents the young generation and it's
going to grow spiritually from what
happened at columbine but it's rachel's
tears
it's a set small sacrifices that she
made for others
it's her story and her death that's
going to allow that growth to happen
so we we we have to get back to being a
country where we recognize that we're
that we're more than just body and mind
that we we have a spirit we have
something and
if we can do that we can tap into an
immense power
you know hearing that story which i had
not heard before it
reminds me of a line that might sum it
all up which is all nature is but art
unknown to thee all chance direction
which thou canst not see and of course
the rose
the symbolism of the rose even beyond
the country goes
down to the heart of our faith craig we
have to leave it there craig scott
the organization is value up craig where
can people find you
valueup.org i'm uh i'm really hoping
that i can get back out there and get
this message out to a lot of teens
i do too absolutely brilliant uh really
really inspiring stuff such a pleasure
wish we could have gone on about uh
seven more hours
but i'm sure sure hopefully there will
be more time in the future
you'll like it get ben to give me a call
that sounds good yeah not shapiro we can
have shapiro give you a call too
ben davies are our producer as well and
you can go check out the movie that
coincidentally my producer happens to be
in and he i hate to admit it
he does a very good job craig thank you
so much for coming on
absolutely thanks for having me on